hola a todos ahora que ya tenemos una
cuenta creada en khan academy como
maestros vamos a iniciar sesión en la
esquina superior derecha vamos a darle
clic aquí donde dice iniciación y vamos
a poner nuestro correo electrónico en la
contraseña con las que nos creamos una
cuenta para poder empezar a usar khan
academy como maestros yo pongo aquí
el mail que me cree la cuenta
y mi contraseña
y le pongo iniciar sesión al clic aquí
ahora khan academy me lleva a la página
principal como más vamos a empezar en
nuestro rol de maestros a crear una
clase para comenzar a trabajar con los
estudiantes
entonces le vamos a dar clic aquí en la
derecha donde dice agregar una clase
de forma muy sencilla lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es ponerle el nombre
de la clase y aquí sugerimos que se
ponga el nombre real de la clase por
ejemplo si yo soy maestro de matemáticas
de quinto grado
por ejemplo pongamos el nombre exacto
y una vez que pongamos el nombre que
queremos con el que se reconozca nuestra
clase le damos click al botón donde dice
siguiente en la parte inferior
ahora nos pide que pongamos el tema o el
curso de nuestra clase no en el caso de
los profesores de matemáticas pueden ser
temas específicos como aritmética pre
álgebra geometría entre otros pero si
queremos hacer varios sistemas de
matemática se les sugiere que hagan clic
en el mundo de las matemáticas en la
parte inferior porque este curso
incorpora todos los cursos anteriores de
matemáticas si somos profesores de
ciencias haremos lo mismo en la parte de
ciencias biología química física
ingeniería economía o en la parte
inferior también la parte de computación
no también podemos elegir yo en este
caso he elegido el mundo de las
matemáticas y le vamos a dar clic a
siguiente
ahora el tercer paso muy sencillo es
agregar estudiantes a una clase y aquí
nos da la plataforma tres opciones una
es si tuviéramos ya instalados en
nuestros colegios la plataforma de
google classroom esa es una forma muy
fácil de sincronizar nuestra clase con
la clase ya creada de google clase otra
forma es invitar a los estudiantes a que
se unan a la clase compartiendo les el
código de la clase
vamos a compartirles un link de un
código específico en el que cada uno de
estudiantes tendrá que unirse a la clase
de profesor otra opción es que el
maestro cree las cuentas para los
alumnos directamente vamos a ver
en esta oportunidad estas dos opciones
además es importante en la parte
inferior se dice que antes de invitar a
los alumnos tener en cuenta de khan
academy supone que has recibido el
permiso de los padres de cualquier
estudiante menor de 13 años no hice es
importante porque es nos parece vital
que los padres estén informados de sus
hijos vamos a comenzar a usar esta
plataforma y que van a crearse cuentas
entonces en este caso si uno le hace
clic donde dice descarga una muestra de
aviso
la plataforma nos sugiere opción es
bueno en varios idiomas le vamos a dar
clic a la que dice en español nos
sugiere una carta para los padres de
familia en las que les podemos contar
que se va a usar canacar en la casa en
esta carta se dice estimado padre madre
o tutor este año situaremos khan academy
en clase para personalizar el proceso de
aprendizaje de todos los estudiantes
acá se le cuenta un poco que se trata la
plataforma y además se le da la opción
al padre para que también él pueda
acompañar el progreso de sus hijos o le
dan un poco el paso a paso de como él
podría hacer para acompañar el
seguimiento de sus hijos
además se le pide por ejemplo en esta
parte final por favor de volver esta
hoja firmada mañana a clase para que el
maestro sepa que tiene el consentimiento
cuando son estudiantes menores
de que comiencen a usar khan academy
cada estudiante con una cuenta personal
ahora volvemos de la plataforma primero
vamos a a
a ver cómo se une a los estudiantes en
la opción 2 que es la de compartirles un
link o código le hacemos clic en esta
segunda opción y lo que me dice es que
le empiezas a tus alumnos que creen sus
propias cuentas como lo crearon los
maestros no
copiando este link en la parte superior
en la barra superior derecha
o agregando este código
en sus tutores esto lo vamos a ver poco
a poco en los siguientes pasos ahora le
vamos a dar clic a siguiente
en el caso nos pregunta la plataforma
donde estamos enseñando bueno la primera
opción es en eeuu pero nosotros vamos en
el perú entonces vamos a poner
profesores en otros países
y vamos a buscar a perú le vamos a dar
click y vamos a darle después a
siguiente sobre la clase ya está creada
de una forma muy sencilla y vamos a
explorar los contenidos del mundo de las
matemáticas que es el curso que yo elegí
entonces como ven aquí en la parte
superior aparece el nombre del curso que
yo puse en matemáticas junto a el mundo
de las matemáticas y en la parte derecha
está el código de la clase y este código
de la clase es independiente para cada
clase que yo creé no lo ideal como les
decía es que tengan una clase creada por
cada clase real que ustedes tengan si
tienen por ejemplo si yo enseñara en
matemática en matemáticas en quinto a
quinto de sexto a 6º ve en una clase
creada para cada una de ellas y luego de
forma muy sencilla voy a poder asignar
tareas para todos al mismo tiempo o
hacerlo individualmente
entonces ahora lo que quiero que
conozcamos
eso
primero el contenido de que ustedes
tienen acceso cuando tienen una clase
creada
por ejemplo imaginemos que yo dentro de
mi clase de matemáticas de 5º a quiero
buscar contenidos de aritmética no de
fracciones por ejemplo dentro de
métricas de lo que es la aritmética le
hago clic aquí en la flecha que está a
la izquierda
y se va a desprender todos los
contenidos de aritmética que tiene la
plataforma que no son temas como sumas
restas multiplicaciones división números
negativos fracciones decimales dentro de
fracciones por ejemplo que es el tema
que me interesa hay otros como
introducción a las fracciones fracciones
en la recta numérica o fracciones
equivalentes comprar fracciones
denominadores comunes hay muchísimo
contenido para lo que el maestro
necesite vamos a imaginar que yo quiero
tocar el tema de las fracciones en la
recta numérica aquí le vuelvo a hacer
clic dentro de esta flecha y se
desprenden los contenidos que tengo para
las fracciones en la recta numérica y
aquí como pueden ver hay primero un
vídeo de cuatro minutos de que se
explica el tema luego hay otro vídeo de
un minuto en el que se habla de las
fracciones en la recta numérica
interactiva luego hay un ejercicio de
siete preguntas son las rectas en las
fracciones en la recta numérica y otros
en las fracciones unitarias
entonces vamos a ver uno del primero de
los vídeos para que tengan una idea de
qué tipo de contenido tiene canacar y le
hacemos click aquí
e inmediatamente nos aparece una versión
preliminar
hemos visto que si tenemos un entero
pensaremos que este círculo amarillo es
un entero y lo dividimos en cinco partes
iguales 1 2 3 4 5 puedo decir entonces
que tengo este entero con
cinco partes iguales estamos bien si yo
dibujo una de estas partes iguales en
color rojo tendré algo así
y entonces podré decir que tengo un
quinto este es un vídeo como ven aquí de
42 minutos y 29 segundos muy sencillos
en el que se explica el tema de las
fracciones y seguro que si vamos un
poquito más adelante ya se habla de la
recta como esto se ve en la recta
numérica
vamos a avanzar lo un poco
esto en cinco partes iguales veamos una
3 4 y 5 pensamos que estas son cinco
partes iguales
si yo buscara representar de estas cinco
partes iguales el recorrido de una
pues haré algo muy sencillo del 0 del 0
me moveré una posición hacia el 1
esta es una explicación muy sencilla que
normalmente damos los maestros
en la pizarra de los alumnos pero aquí
lo tienen en un vídeo que el alumno
puede ver cuantas veces lo necesiten
entonces una vez que ya lo vi lo puedo
poner aquí a cerrarlo
y yo puedo decir bueno me interesa que
este tema lo vean mis alumnos
hago click en
en esta flecha en esta casilla de aquí
en la derecha luego quiero ver
imaginemos cuáles son los ejercicios de
las fracciones en la recta normal en
todos lados clic aquí
y puedo ver aquí no
22 preguntas de esta sección
si yo estoy de acuerdo con que estos son
temas ejercicios importantes para el
tema que quiero tocar simplemente los
cierro y le doy clic a esta casilla
yo puedo elegir cada uno de estos temas
así por separado o puedo elegir en la
parte superior de dice las facciones una
recta numérica
luego clic aquí y ya se asignaron los
cuatro sirven en la parte superior dicen
cuatro porque se han asignado los las
cuatro piezas dos vídeos y dos
ejercicios esta es la forma de elegir
cuáles son los temas que quiero para mí
es para asignarle tareas en los
estudiantes
esta es una forma no también imaginemos
que yo quiero dejar todo el tema de
fracciones puedo ir un paso más atrás
donde dice fracciones y lado clic aquí
y en este caso lo que estaría dejando
los estudiantes son 113 parejas entre
vídeos ejercicios también hay artículos
y también hay cuestionarios que son como
mini evaluaciones para que el estudiante
vaya viendo cómo ha avanzado
esto es muy interesante para los
estudiantes porque ellos nos van a ir
viendo su progreso
entonces
tal vez 113 es demasiado entonces nos
vamos a quedar solo con el tema en la
recta numérica que son 4
entonces una vez que yo ya estoy segura
lo que tengo de darle clic aquí asignar
y justamente me sale lo que vimos un
poco en el tour que es quiero es asignar
el conjunto diferente de preguntas para
cada estudiante el mismo con o son
diferentes preguntas o el mismo conjunto
de preguntas para todos los estudiantes
en este caso yo todavía no tengo
estudiantes así que todavía no me va a
dejar asignar entonces le puedo poner en
guardar y asignar más tarde
no estoy aquí
y si vamos a la parte superior derecha
y hacemos clic en tareas
vamos a por tarea
hay una sección donde dice guardadas y
ahí vemos que están nuestras tareas ya
guardadas
lo que tenemos que hacer para que se
agreguen los estudiantes a la clase es
compartirles este código
este código que está en la parte
superior derecha
y que se unan a la clase
como estudiantes
otra forma de asignar tareas que voy a
enseñarles
es mediante el buscador y eso está en la
parte superior izquierda donde dice ven
acá buscar le hacen clic aquí y por
ejemplo ponemos imaginemos que yo quiero
dejar una tarea sobre números
negativos entonces acá me aparecen
rápidamente todos los temas que tiene
canacar en esos números negativos no voy
a darle clic aquí en números negativos y
positivos
y si ven me sale como un buscador como
el de google pero acá aparece todo lo
que tiene canaca de mí sobre números
negativos y positivos
yo puedo filtrar si quiero ver solamente
los vídeos los artículos que tengan el
tema de números negativos ejercicios
también imaginemos que yo quiero este
ejercicio de multiplicar números
negativos entonces le hago clic aquí
los números negativos
me aparecen los ejercicios de
multiplicar números negativos y en la
parte superior me aparece una barra
donde me da la opción también de asignar
a mi clase de matemática y quinto a no
haciendo diferentes preguntas a las
preguntas en este caso vamos a elegir
las mismas preguntas y la fecha para
cual la quisiera dejar en este caso
también vamos a simplemente a guardar lo
vamos a hacer crear que aguardar porque
todavía no se han agregado los
estudiantes al clase
soleado clic a guardar
acá me dice que ya guarde
estos ejercicios si queremos verlos le
hacemos click a la parte superior donde
dice khan academy
vamos a la clase que cree
hacemos clic donde dice tareas
a la opción de guardadas y aquí están
todas las tareas que he ido guardando de
multiplicar números negativos que lo
encontré por el buscador pero también
las que busque por la pestaña de
contenidos y así es como uno va buscando
y asignando tareas a su clase